Four AI video generators. Which one is
the best? Clink 3.0 versus Cance 2.0
versus Sora 2 versus VO 3.1. 20 brutal
prompts without me talking. Just pure
videos. Let's begin.
I told you the code stays with me until
I see the money.
>> I told you the code stays with me until
with the arch.
Get out.
Where are the pilots? I have to take
control.
>> Come on. Come on.
>> I'm trying. Stay with me. Stay with me.
>> Nice left. Now you got traffic at 2
miles.
>> Left. Left. Okay.
finish here. Divine judgment
the empire. They heat in the center.
Harry smart fly. The general's already
pressing.
>> Wind chum toss clips him. He answers
with a solar sweep pushing her to the
wall.
I am so sorry.
Oh my god.
Heat.
Can't let them catch me.
>> Stop. Please. Out of the way. He's
heading north. Stay on him. Stop
running. Come on. Move. HE'S GOING TO
THE ALLEY. Don't lose him.
Heat.
Hey,
great.
Got you.
Huh?
Really?
Hello. Mhm.
>> Huh? What the
In a world of marvels, some creatures
defy all expectations.
This is the incredible story of the
pilot otter. Here we observe a truly
remarkable site. The sleek river otter,
miles from shore, trusts its among the
river banks of the northern forest lives
an animal built for water. But today,
this otter is aiming for the skies.
Outfitted with goggles and an aviation
headset, she pilots a float plane with
the same assurance she shows in the
current. From glacial valleys to
windswept tundra,
Heat.
[__]
So, this is rush hour in Chongqing. And
uh yeah, that's a cat. A really big one.
It's stuck between the towers. Poor guy.
Look at those paws. Wait, watch this.
Bus driver's just going to pet him. Oh,
there goes everyone's hats. Bless you,
big fella. And now he's Yeah, he's
blocking the whole bridge. GUESS
Target's on our left.
>> Keep them busy. I'll handle the rest.
They're pulling ahead.
>> Not for long.
>> Firing. Juiced up and juice harder.
>> Copy. Let's finish this.